president kamala harris is on her first
foreign trip today tackling an urgent
and difficult
issue illegal immigration to the united
states she arrived in guatemala last
night in part to learn why so many
people leave the country
vice president harris is expected to
announce new plans to address
drug and human trafficking ed o'keefe is
in guatemala city for us ed good morning
to you so what's on the vice president's
agenda
tony good morning kamala harris making
history overnight as the first american
woman to arrive in a country
to full military honors as vice
president she'll meet today
with guatemala's president who we
realized has probably spoken to her more
by a telephone and zoomed so far than
many of the people she works with in
washington
but today they'll meet face to face here
at the national palace behind us
to talk about the root causes of illegal
immigration
guatemalan president alejandro yamate
points out he and vice president kamala
harris
have one thing in common she doesn't
hold back which is good
she's frank we're not on the same side
of the coin
we are in agreement in the what which is
something we are not in agreement in the
house
yamate told us a root cause of
undocumented immigration from his
country
is the economy and we saw for ourselves
that in some cases
the root cause of immigration is
literally the roots
that can no longer grow it's forced
parents like lorenzo who struggles to
feed her family
to let her oldest son go north he's now
in houston and sends money twice a month
when was the moment that you knew he had
to go to the united states
we saw that there were some who went who
already have a house
they have clothes for their family they
have clothes that they didn't have
before
and they can eat what they want to eat
things are even more dire for lucia
whose husband also
immigrated to houston and now works in a
restaurant
he sends her a few hundred dollars a
month that she mostly uses to pay off
thousands of dollars in debts
to a bank and human traffickers she says
the coyotes charged her husband
more than 14 thousand dollars for safe
passage
mostly people want to stay in guatemala
they want to be in their homes
they don't want to take that horrific
very expensive
trip to the united states mary mcinerney
a chicago native is country director for
guatemala for save the children
which helps women like lorenz and lucia
if the vice president called you and
said what are the root causes of the
problem
in guatemala what would you tell her the
main one inequity
i mean it's a big one it's really big
but
unfortunately the majority of the poor
and extremely poor
do not have access to food jobs
and education yamate told us targeting
human traffickers
should be a top american priority
we asked her to introduce a bill in the
u.s senate which would declare the
coyotes federal criminals you'd like
coyotes to be prosecuted in the united
states under federal law
yes that's correct and we ask the us to
broaden our extradition treaty
one other thing to watch for today how
much talk is there about covid19
vaccines
the u.s has already committed 500
thousand doses to guatemala leaders here
would like more
but an independent watchdog group we
talked to says there's concerns
that the country is already struggling
to put shots in the arms with the little
supply that they have
the vice president heads tonight to
mexico where she'll meet with president
andres manuel lopez obrador
tomorrow in mexico city anthony ed
o'keefe in guatemala this morning thanks
ed